okay before we get into the show today I
got to tell you about big token okay big
token is a new app that lets you share
data about yourself your interest your
habits and then you get paid for it okay
that's the important part right now you
know you share an enormous amount of
information with tech companies and the
thing is they're the ones who make money
off of it instead of you so I think you
should get in on that action and that's
where big token comes in here's how it
works first you download the app and you
sign up for a free big token account
next you complete actions to get points
so actions include things like answering
surveys checking into locations
connecting your your social accounts and
stuff like that and then you can redeem
your points for rewards such as cash or
gift cards you can donate your earnings
to charity
you could choose what data you share
with big token and and so it's up to you
and then you get paid for it that's
that's the point
the surveys in the app will ask general
questions about your demographics and
your lifestyle and specific follow-up
questions based on what you answered and
there are also surveys around specific
holidays or events big token has other
social features like in-app messaging
with your friends creating a team to
answer questions together and earn even
more that way you can also get more
points for referring friends and family
your data is always secured with big
token based on the data you choose to
share you will be placed into specific
ad groups and brands will buy access to
those ad groups for use in personalized
advertising the best part you get paid
and this is all up to you it's your
choice if you want to participate in it
then in if the information is going to
be shared then you might as well get a
piece of the of the of the pie if you
want to start earning money for your
data download the big token app and use
my referral code which is Walsh ok let's
begin now with the most important news
item of the day it's the thing that
everyone's talking about breaking news I
don't know if you saw this over the
weekend but President Trump's new hairdo
look at this thing right here it he
debuted this over the weekend and I'm
hearing reports that it's actually not a
intentional hairstyle just his hat hair
he took
hat off and that's what his hair looks
like under his hat but I think he needs
to go with this this is a game changer
for 2020 this is in my opinion now I am
NOT a stylist I'm not an expert in these
things my wife tells me that I am
stylistically challenged sometimes but
to me gut reaction this is ten million
times better than its normal haircut and
it is it just it changes everything
I think we need to get president Trump
with that hairstyle and and then put Ted
Cruz with his new beard on a ticket
together and from a purely from from
from just a basis from a follicle basis
from a follicular if that's a word basis
I think that that would make an
unstoppable combination I like the hair
stuff you know why because it's yeah
it's a little bit startling because it's
not is his weird usual thing is iconic
at this point part of who he is but I
like the hairstyle because it's it's
normal it's just what a normal hairstyle
should be when I was a kid my mom would
take me to the barber and she would tell
the barber normal boys cut that was my
haircut when I was a kid normal boys cut
and so this looks to me just to be like
a normal man's cut and and that's good a
lot of people on social media have been
making fun of the president for this
haircut saying it looks like Gordon
Gekko or what's what's wrong with that
you know I mean and they'll make fun of
them no matter what so my plea to the
president is do not listen to those
people who are making fun of you it is I
then go with this this changes
everything all right so maybe on
slightly more important news only
slightly you know it's often said that
the these sort of anti media sentiments
in our country the hostility to the
media has been created by Donald Trump
that he's the one who's making everyone
hate the media this obviously is false
people hated the media way before Donald
Trump came along I myself come from a
long line of media haters this is subway
we have a long tradition in my family it
runs in our blood of hating the media I
can remember you know being a kid
and my dad really hated the media he
still does I can distinctly remember the
sounds that would come from you know the
the living room when my dad was
downstairs watching TV watching the news
because he would watch the news every
night even though he hated the media and
he would watch the news during
especially during the Clinton
administration he would just be shouting
at the TV screaming at the news anchor
and and then I would eventually grow up
one day to also watch TV and scream at
news anchors although I don't watch the
news that much partially because I want
to save my vocal cords point is people
hated the media for a long time now
because of Trump and we have good reason
I could cite any number of reads like
there's a million reasons I could choose
from but let's just go with the latest
here's the latest reason to hate the
media and it's a pretty significant one
you may recall maybe you recall that
meme from a few weeks ago showing Nancy
Pelosi giving a speech and slurring her
words to make it look like she was drunk
now this is not the same video there was
one there's this video and then there
was a different video of Nancy Pelosi
stammering that President Trump shared
it's not that video okay this is a
different one and this is a video that I
actually had not heard of until this
whole thing happened over the weekend
up until this I had and I hadn't heard
of it or seen it but it's it's just it
shows her as it's slurring her words and
apparently the videos been messed with
someone slowed it down to make it seem
like she was you know drunk or something
and it went viral on Facebook and on
Twitter and but then very quickly after
that video went viral the real footage
got out there and everyone understood
that it was that the original thing was
doctored and you know it's not a real
video you know so
I don't know if there was any real
damage done to Nancy Pelosi because of
this I think probably not probably none
at all I doubt that any of her potential
voters were turned off by a fake video
that went viral on right-wing
conservative pages for a few days before
the national media spent several more
days debunking it well we thought we'd
all moved on with our lives right after
this video apparently came out but
evidently not because The Daily Beast
was on the case they were hunting down
whoever created the original video and
finally they found him and yesterday on
Sunday they doxed him they published a
news article with his name where he
lives personal details criminal record
work history everything and he's just
some random private citizen who made a
fake Pelosi video on Facebook and for
that crime for that sin The Daily Beast
dragged him out onto the public stage
and they shamed him in front of the
entire world The Daily Beast article
that's up on their site right now is by
Kevin Poulsen
and Paulson has been applauded in the
liberal press for this in fact the way
that I found out about this article
originally is that some other
journalists shared it and said you know
with it with a caption like incredible
work by The Daily Beast it was a great
job or something like that and so I
clicked on it said oh well what's what
incredible job did they do I'm
interested in the Daily Beast doesn't
usually do incredible jobs with things
but I was interested so I clicked on it
and I was immediately horrified so let
me read a few I'll read a little bit of
this article I'm going to admit the
guy's name even though his name is out
there everywhere I don't want to be part
I don't want to be part of the effort to
spread his name out there so I'll omit
his name but this is we read a little
bit from The Daily Beast article says on
May 22nd a Donald Trump super fan an
occasional sports blogger from the Bronx
named blank posted a video clip of Nancy
Pelosi on his personal Facebook page the
clip showed Pelosi at her most excitable
stammering during a press conference as
she voiced frustration over an aboard of
infrastructure meeting with the Pres
Blanks commentary on the video was
succinct is Pelosi drunk 13 minutes
later a Facebook official pay attention
to this part 13 minutes later a Facebook
official told The Daily Beast that Blanc
posted a very different Pelosi video to
a Facebook page called politics watchdog
one of a series of hyper-partisan news
operations that he runs with help he
claims this clip has been altered to
slow Pelosi down with lowering the plate
while lowering the pitch of her voice
the effect was to make it look like she
was drunk la blah blah 15 minutes after
that the same doctored video appeared on
the second Facebook page that he manages
and then it spreads from there they
talked about how it spreads the video
was an instant social media smash
surging through the Internet's well-worn
lines of credulity and venom I was
shared by James Wood and Rudy Giuliani
so on and so forth and then it gets into
talking about this guy's personal life
says blank a 34 year old day laborer
currently on probation after pleading
guilty to domestic battery claims that
his drunk commentary on an on an
unaltered Pelosi video had no connection
to the now infamous fake clip that
premiered less than 15 minutes later he
says I wasn't the individual created the
Pelosi video he and he insisted in a
telephone interview it's conceivable
that someone else actually edited the
clip but a Facebook official confirming
a Daily Beast investigation said the
video was first posted on politics
watchdog directly from blanks personal
Facebook account and then it goes into
more about the Facebook pages that he
that he manages okay and it goes on from
there it's a lengthy expose it's very
long about remember this is a lengthy
expose about some random blue-collar guy
who posted a allegedly posted a Nancy
Pelosi video he says he didn't even he
wasn't even the one who posted it it
goes into more detail about his private
life his work history and Polson
the guy who wrote this article admits
admits that the guy the article is about
didn't want to be outed like this it
says at first blank didn't respond to
emails phone calls text messages
Facebook messages and a direct message
over Instagram and he blocked this
reporter on Twitter okay so this this
reporter is harassing this guy until
finally he relents on Friday he called
back explaining that he was worried over
the prospect of being publicly linked to
the fitty to the video fakery I'm in New
York City New York City he said very
liberal people make judgments I just
don't want to be linked to a
conservative right winger and be
potentially denied services and stuff
people are nasty you should see some of
the messages that are coming in but they
published all of his personal details
anyway he said he doesn't want to be
published he's worried about the effect
it would have on him yet they did it
anyway
so what is the point of this can it be
justified on any level can it be seen as
anything other than cruel partisan
vengeance well as for partisan it's it's
clearly partisan there's no question
about that does anyone think that in a
million years the daily beast would hunt
down someone who made a negative meme
about a Republican I mean about Donald
Trump there are a lot of negative memes
about Donald Trump there are a lot of
doctored videos of Donald Trump out
there do you think The Daily Beast is
going to go hunt down any of those
people no of course not
in fact let's use a real-world example
someone initially took the full video of
the the Covington Catholic students two
now infamous video of the Covington
Catholic students someone took that
whole video it's like an hour and a half
long and they cropped out the context
and they put the out of context video
online a video which proceeded to put
the lives of those kids in danger I mean
there were death threats and bomb
threats to the school
and a video that could have possibly
destroyed their lives if not for a
counter campaign you know among
conservatives to get the truth out there
and to end to defend these these boys
but do you think the Daily Beast would
Docs whoever put that video out there
did they Doc's that person know so yeah
it's partisan of course as for cruel and
vengeful well look I'll be the first to
say that I don't think you have some
kind of carte blanche general
expectation of or right to privacy when
you're online what I mean is if you say
or do something anonymously online I
don't think that your anonymity has to
always be respected I think it depends
now you may recall a few weeks ago when
I was on here giving me the names and
Twitter handles of people who had
threatened and and or wished rape and
death on my on my wife and my children
and myself for my pro-life stance and I
didn't doc Ock's those people daxing is
when you go digging for personal
information that's not readily available
and then you put it out there for
everyone to see I didn't do that if they
had their names attached to their
Twitter handles then I said what their
names were but that's it so there was no
doxxing but I did remove to some extent
their anonymity because these were
messages that they sent me privately and
I took those private messages and I made
them public now in that case I felt
completely justified and I would
absolutely do it again without
hesitation because if you come to me if
you message me threatening my family and
my kids and my and my wife and myself
I'm gonna let everyone know what you
said you should have to stand by your
words publicly I'm not gonna respect
your privacy when your privately sending
me messages threatening to my families
it doesn't work that way if you're gonna
do that if you're gonna take the time to
send me a private message threatening my
family I'm gonna put it out there it's
just as fair is fair if you don't want
that then don't send me those messages
don't
come to me like that I wasn't hunting
anybody down they came to me and I
simply said hey everybody look at what
this person said you made that choice so
now you have to live with the
consequences but that in my mind is very
different from what the daily beast has
done for one thing this guy isn't
threatening anybody he's not threatening
anyone's spouse or children
he isn't personally harassing anyone he
just put a video out on Facebook and the
people going after him were not affected
by it so listen if Nancy Pelosi herself
was it was offended by this video and
she wanted to get up there and say oh so
you know so-and-so put this video of me
out there and she wanted to name the guy
then I would probably say okay fair's
fair she's defending herself you did
make the fake video of her she named you
you started it in essence so she
defended herself
that's fine but that's not what happened
and the point is here that this isn't
newsworthy just like the people who came
after me that wasn't newsworthy either
either but I took it personally because
they were threatening my family and so I
defended myself
it wasn't about trying to pretend it was
news I was just personally responding to
those people to know to punish them for
what they had said to me
so if Pelosi had taken it personally and
decided to respond then then fine but
that's not what happened the problem is
that the media takes it personally when
Democrats are attacked they act like
Nancy Pelosi is good personal friends or
something you know they're getting
defensive and lashing out against people
who attack her or other Democrats so
they're acting like her personal PR team
that's the issue here the identity of
this guy is not news it doesn't matter
he does not matter on a national level
I'm sure he'd be the first person to say
that yet the media came after him
vengefully to send a message and the
message is
mess with our people that's that's
really the that's that's the problem so
you know i I've I've heard some people
defending the Daily Beast's behavior
here by saying well this guy chose to
put a video out there so he had it
coming
but again that's that's not what the
media that's not what the news media is
supposed to do it's not their job to
give people what's what's coming to them
you know it's not their job to to be
defensive of Democrats who are attacked
the question is their job is to report
the news their job is to tell us what is
newsworthy and this guy's personal
identity and his work history and his
criminal record none of that is
newsworthy you and I is just average
consumers of the news
we can't do anything with that that
information does nothing for us it
doesn't matter to us at all but I think
there's a there's something about this
story that's even more disturbing and
then the fact that the media is daxing
this guy and that is that if you caught
this part Facebook gave user information
to a Daily Beast reporter let's uh let's
go back and read this part again it says
13 minutes later a Facebook official
told The Daily Beast blank posted a very
different Pelosi video to a Facebook
page called politics watchdog and then
at one other point in the article talks
about how Facebook confirmed that this
guy posted the video okay so so Facebook
will tell the media about your
activities on Facebook if they call and
ask it's really that simple I mean it's
it's
not even like police you know coming
with a warrant it's just it's someone
with the daily beast who calls up
Facebook and says hey hey did did this
person post that at this time can you
can you check and let me know and they
went and looked and said yep uh-huh
anything else you need any more
information you need access to his
private messages or anything just let us
know and we'll help you out that is uh
that's that's that's terrifying and that
has got to be a violation of their terms
of service now I'll admit that you know
as as probably with with most people
when you know when I when I get those
lengthy terms of services online I I
don't really read the entire thing all
it omits stupid we probably should most
of us don't but I'm guessing that
there's nothing in the Terms of Service
that says that Facebook has the right to
share your personal information with the
news media if they just ask I'm guessing
that probably isn't in there so this
guy's got I think a lawsuit he's got
grounds for a lawsuit at least based on
that and that you know to me that
actually is the headline it's not that
the Daily Beast doxed this Trump
supporter because we expect that of them
unfortunately it's that Facebook doxed
its own users for apparently political
reasons that is uh just horrifying and
terrifying okay a couple other items
related to the media first the cast of
Handmaid's Tale was on CNN yesterday and
there's an article on cnn.com about
about it and about what they had to say
and the the the cast of pent maids tale
they were talking about how the United
States is turning into the Handmaid's
Tale we're almost there
you know we're we're honest
slippery slope into living in that
patriarchal dystopia and you hear this a
lot of course about how America is a
Handmaid's Tale but you know what
America is not the head maids tale and
you know how I know that well because
it's just a stupid claim for one but
also the number one clue that America is
not the Handmaid's Tale is that The
Handmaid's Tale exists so that's that's
how you know that's how you know we're
not in the Handmaid's Tale and that
we're not anywhere close to the hem of a
cell because we live in a country where
women can make millions of dollars
portraying America as a patriarchal
dystopia if we actually worried
patriarchal dystopia or close to a
patriarchal dystopia well you wouldn't
be able to do that so that's just a this
is just one little just to allay your
fears as long as Handmaid's Tale is on
TV I think we're good
also one other note about the media the
hill has an article on their website
with a curious headline and the headline
is headline says poll nearly half of
Americans say Supreme Court should
uphold roe v wade now of course
intuitive people hear that headline and
they think well hold on a second well
nearly half of Americans say the Supreme
Court should uphold roe v wade that's
the headline you're giving us nearly
half want roe v-- wade uphill well
doesn't that mean that more than half
don't want that well yes it does let's
read the second paragraph of this
article about a Harvard poll now
remember they made the headline about
the almost half who want to uphold roe v
wade but here's the second paragraph
under the headline
it says 46% of respondents said the High
Court should uphold the ruling in Roe if
the issue comes before the justices
while 36% said the Supreme Court should
modify the 46 year old ruling
18% wanted the ruling to be overturned
altogether so what's the real headline
more than half of Americans want Roe
overturned or modified that's the real
headline and in fact it's better than
that because let's go to the end of the
article it says a plurality 41% said the
procedure should be allowed only in
cases of rape or incest so 41% only want
abortion in cases of rape or incest
that's a I'm actually surprised by how
high that number is 29% said it should
be permitted up until the first
trimester of pregnancy while 17% said
that it should be allowed until the
second trimester only 8% said abortion
should be permitted up until the third
trimester and 6% said the procedure
should be allowed up until the birth of
the child so 92% of Americans do not
support late term abortion even though
support for late term abortion is
mainstream among Democrat politicians
you know almost every Democrat on the
federal level among the among the
political class support late term
abortion they support abortion from you
know from the very moment of conception
all the way till the moment of birth and
actually abortion up till the moment of
birth 94% of Americans are against that
according to this poll which is a
staggering number and it shows you just
how out of touch
how fringe how radical the the Democrat
Party has become on this issue 94% of
Americans disagree with them on the
abortion issue but of course the hill
they don't make that the headline the
headline for them is that nearly half of
Americans say that a Supreme Court
should uphold roe v wade this is just
it's one of the most disingenuous and
misleading headlines that we've seen
probably this year which is saying quite
a lot but it also shows you just how the
media
able to mislead the public because
remember that you know probably 90% or
more of the people who see a headline
will not click on it and even among the
people who click on it most will just
read the first sentence or the first two
sentences and then skim the rest if they
even skim the rest at all so the idea is
just put that headline out there and
most people are gonna see it and they're
gonna and they're not going to think
about it and they're gonna they're gonna
say okay well so you know most Americans
are what they see is that a lot of
Americans want to uphold roe v-- wade
that's what most people are gonna take
from that headline because they're not
going to click and read and so that's
the the idea behind it all right one
last thing before we get emails it's
it's June you know and and June is Pride
Month if you haven't heard Pride Month
is a time for people with certain sexual
attractions to talk about how proud they
are of those sexual attractions of
course keep in mind that people's sex
lives are none of our business
it's none of our business but there's a
whole month set aside to talk about it
which is a little bit confusing that's
that's it's hard to square those two
things is it our business or not our
business if it's not our business then
why are you spending a month talking
about it you know it's it's a little bit
strange but never mind don't try to make
sense of that one thing that's kind of
funny about this month is to see all of
the major companies in the world
tripping over themselves to virtue
signal and and celebrate pride in in
these increasingly weird and
embarrassing ways and that's kind of
interesting because
it isn't what you would expect based on
the fact that we're told that LGBT folks
are oppressed in this country
we're told that they're they're
oppressed yet all of the most wealthy
and powerful forces in the country will
spend the month trying to flatter LGBT
people that's not usually how oppression
works
in fact that's usually a hint that
you're not in an oppressed group if
people are doing everything they can to
flatter you and celebrate you and
applaud you that probably means you're
not being systematically oppressed black
people were truly oppressed
systematically oppressed in this country
prior to civil rights and based on my
reading of history back in those days
the rich and powerful forces in America
they were not in a mad rush to celebrate
black power it was kind of the opposite
Jews were oppressed in Nazi Germany and
again you did not see the powerful
forces in that culture trying to flatter
Jews again it was in precisely the
opposite so you know if this is an
oppression it's a very subtle form of
oppression I've hit it it is so subtle
that you would almost think it doesn't
exist just a thought but in any case
Budweiser has gotten in on the action
Budweiser a company that makes rusty tap
water which it somehow gets away with
calling beer Budweiser has you know
taking a hit in recent years financially
because people have discovered that real
beer exists and so we don't really need
Budweiser so I guess they're desperate
for attention and in an effort to get
attention they've unveiled a new series
of cups which celebrate pride and but
it's not just the normal celebration of
gay pride or whatever this is this is
these are worth taking a look at so
let's let's look at some of these okay
so the first one just kind of normal
what you would expect it says fly the
flag for inclusive pride so take a look
at this says in 2017 the city of
Philadelphia added a black and brown
stripe to the classic rainbow design to
better represent people of color within
the community it has since been flown at
prides around the world now okay but I
don't really understand why you need to
add brown and black to represent brown
and black people because the normal
pride flag has like pink and green and
purple right there are it's not like the
pink and green and purple are there to
celebrate pink green and purple people I
thought the colors had nothing to do
with race so I don't know why you have
to add the racial colors in there it
doesn't really make any sense but anyway
and the next one is so this one is fly
the flag for by pride
it says magenta is for same gender
attraction blue is for attraction to
genders other than your own and lavender
a mix of the two represents attraction
to your own and other genders though
some interpret it differently okay and
then fly the flag for lesbian pride says
while this flag is commonly used it's
it's it isn't the only one if you look
around you might see a version with a
kiss in the corner representing lipstick
lesbians whatever that is I've no idea
or a purple flag with a double-headed
axe for labyrinth feminist pride I don't
know what that means
okay but now things start getting weird
it's already weird but now it's gonna
start getting weird weirder so this one
is fly the flag for non-binary pride it
says yellow is for those whose gender
exists outside of the gender binary
white is for people with many genders
purple is for those who feel a mix of
male and female and black is for those
who feel they're without you any gender
entirely now ways like a but I thought
black was for black people now it's for
black people or those who have no gender
so in other words it's for black people
or people who don't exist because
there's no such thing as a person with
no gender that doesn't exist on earth
never has never will but so okay so
we've we've expanded black and now it
includes those two things then it says
fly the flag for pan pride pan pride not
like a frying pan blue symbolizes male
attraction pink feet symbolizes female
attraction and yellow attraction to
other genders so how is that different
from
then we already cover all of that I
don't know fly the flag for intersex
pride the circle symbolizes wholeness
and completeness while purple and yellow
were chosen as they don't have female or
male associations
okay but purple and yellow have have
like 19 other associations don't they
we've already used purple and yellow on
every other flag so you're saying it has
no other associations yeah I mean you're
cramming too many things in each of
these colors it doesn't make any sense
but now this this really is what I
wanted to this is this is the only one
we need to focus on so get ready for
this one last one fly the flag for a
sexual pride it says black is for
asexuals who don't feel sexual
attraction to anyone gray is for grey
sexuals who sometimes feel sexual
attraction and demisexuals who only feel
it if they know someone well white nods
to nons asexual allies and purple
represents the whole community it's okay
so we're using purple again so it
represents like 952 different things and
and then we're using black again so
black represents black people or people
with no gender who don't exist or people
who feel no sexual attraction to anyone
that's what black means on the flag now
of course there are probably like for
actual asexual people on earth if there
are any at all which I'm skeptical of
actually because to be able to be a real
asexual you would have to never
experience any sexual attraction to
anyone ever that will be a really really
asexual person is someone who never
feels sexually attracted to anyone any
shape size at all if that group exists
it is numerically very close to
non-existence but however many of them
are out there what does it mean to take
pride in being asexual what does that
mean you're proud of not being attracted
to people now if you're not attracted to
people you're not attracted to them I'm
not saying that you should be
of that I mean if that's just if that's
how you are then I mean you can't help
it but but what does it mean to be proud
of it like how does that work how can
you be a proud of an attraction you
don't have you're proud of your absence
of attraction I mean isn't it I like
it's not like marching to express your
pride in the fact that you don't like
ham sandwiches if you don't like ham
sandwiches that's fine but you don't
need to you don't need to throw a parade
about it that's what I'm saying so what
are you proud of exactly and then
demisexuals are those who need to get to
know someone before feeling attracted
all right so those are just women in
other words that's just what that's that
that's a woman women are less Vigil
visual in their sexual appetites and
they tend to be attracted more based on
personality and that's the kind of thing
so those are just normal women so we've
got asexuals which include four people
on earth then demisexuals which include
three and a half billion people so
things are a little bit lopsided here
and then we get to grey sexual and those
are people who sometimes feel sexual
attraction all right so now that's just
literally everybody in the world
that's just seven billion people because
everyone sometimes feel sexual
attraction I guess except for the four
asexuals out there the only other option
is to walk around always sexually
attracted to every human animal and
object you come across that's that's the
other option if it's if it's either
never sexually attracted or sometimes
sexually attracted or always sexually
attracted to everything which by the way
why aren't those people represented what
would that be if you're if you're always
sexually a trap if you're sexually
attracted to literally everything in
existence like a man a woman a desk a
tree a dog a rock the sky I mean I guess
that's because that's the other option
here and and and I don't know what that
would be would that be like we need a
name for that I'm not clever enough to
come up with a name right now but
they need to be in the acronym Universal
attraction as I something like that you
yoona yoona sexual now that sounds like
your only I don't know I would think
that that would be pansexual anyway we
can work on that but regardless if
you're not that and you're not asexual
then that means you're going to be
sometimes sexual and that you're you're
sometimes sexually attracted but then
sometimes you're not depending on
depending on what's around you I suppose
so that's approximately 7 billion people
and which means that we all get to be in
the acronym the acronym has been
expanded to include now 7 billion people
and this is what I'm talking about that
people are so desperate to be included
to be included in the supposedly
oppressed LGBT category that they're
making up label labels that make no
sense just so they can be included it's
become a very sought after Club to be in
and that is not how oppression works if
you live in a country where there is a
really systematically oppressed group of
people you are not going to be clamoring
to be included in that group unless
you're you know some kind of masochist
which I think they might be in the
acronym to I'm not sure there they are
I'm pretty sure they are but unless your
mask is you you wouldn't want to be in
the group the fact that everybody wants
to be in the group and that we're making
up labels just so we can get in that
group just goes to show you that this is
not an oppressed group in fact it shows
you that the opposite is the case it
shows you that this is a privileged
group this is a group that if you're if
you're in that group it affords you
social and legal privileges that's why
people want to be in it that's what
people to a group is the privileges that
they will gain if they're a part of it
alright um so there you go so I've
become a very long acronym mat wall show
at gmail.com mat wall show at gmail.com
is the email address we'll read a few of
your emails here this is from Lou says
hi Matt I know you've been joking about
your Achilles injury this week I respect
that you have a good sense of humor
about it but in all seriousness how are
you doing with it is it a full tear
I've never injured my Achilles but I
have broken multiple bones of my leg and
foot at various points in my life I'd
always heard that an Achilles taro is
the worst injury you can sustain on your
leg extremely painful and very hard to
recover from I don't mean to be
discouraging I'm sure you already knew
this but I'm concerned about you and I'm
wondering how you're actually feeling
and doing aside from the jokes Lou I
really appreciate that email and this is
I've got several emails like this of
people who are just genuinely concerned
and I do appreciate that because that's
to take the time to write an email you
know of expressing concern and sympathy
for someone that you don't even know
personally it's just a very it's a very
it's a kindness so I appreciate that it
is a full addict I know I haven't been
I'm going to the doctor after the show
to you know get all the details and talk
about treatment and stuff but I did call
the I talked to the doctor with the MRI
results over the weekend and they they
read the MRI results there was a lot of
stuff in the results I didn't understand
but I did understand the phrase full and
extensive tear of the Achilles which i
think is probably not good probably not
what you want to hear not a doctor but
you know so it is a full full and
extensive - so that's good um yeah it's
it does hurt I mean when it first
happened it felt like a gunshot to the
back of the leg it's extremely extremely
painful I've never been shot but I feel
like it I mean I don't know I I think
it's probably in that realm as far as
pain goes it's just um you know it's
when you go to the doctor they asked
they asked you to rate your pain on a
scale of one to ten and so there is kind
of like you get
to a limit where it just a thing can't
be any more painful than it's like 10 is
kind of the limit and so I think it was
pretty close to a 10 maybe a nine but
ever since then you know it's it's it
mostly it feels okay there are moments
of searing intense pain but for the most
part it's it's fine as for how I'm doing
and you know I was talking about this
yesterday that it has been in I've been
actually strangely encouraged by the
fact that I've had this torn Achilles
now for a week and I've been to the
doctor I don't know three or four times
over the week and I still have not been
prescribed painkillers with a torn
Achilles they haven't gave me pain they
just say take tylenol and put ice on
which which is fine because I don't
really want pink I'd like if they gave
me oxycontin or something I wouldn't
take it because I just I'd be too afraid
of I just I'd rather not I'd rather just
deal with the pain and take tylenol
personally but it was not what I
expected because I kind of thought that
doctors hand out painkillers like candy
and that's how half the country got
hooked on the stuff but as I said I've
been to the doctor three or four times
with a torn Achilles unable to walk and
they don't give you painkillers so I'm
just wondering who do they get
painkillers do if not if this doesn't
rate getting a painkiller than what does
as I said I don't really I don't want
one I'm just wondering it's it's curious
although as I was talking about this
online so Twitter yesterday people are
saying that yeah I mean they used to
give up painkillers like candy but now
they've gotten a lot stingy er about it
and so that's good actually I appreciate
that
I was actually encouraged by that
because it's yeah I don't think they
should be just handing out synthetic
heroin to everybody who comes in with a
little minor pain or whatever so I asked
for how I'm doing generally it's you
know objets it's I'm fine it's just I I
just can't walk is the problem and a lot
of people have worse problems than this
but I appreciate as I said their concern
alright um my name is is from Nathan
says my name is Nathan death loth I'm 18
years old
a huge
the show I'm responding to your May 31st
episode entitled Donald Trump caused her
noble in which you give analysis in
depth about the pop / rap / country song
old town road I disagree with your
assertion that old town road OTR
parentheses is the worst song ever
recorded and that one must have an IQ of
25 to enjoy it I think that to
understand why Oh T R is popular one
must first understand the origins of the
song OTR got its start on the social
media site tick tock and which creators
can share short videos usually dubbed
with music the majority of the videos on
this site are comical and meant for
mindless entertainment OTR then became
the subject of memes far and wide across
the internet the song had nearly run its
course until the mastermind behind such
incredible compositions as Achy Breaky
Heart and I want my mullet back Billy
Ray Cyrus remix the song and was
featured on it
this gave lil NAS X is almost comically
bad song the staying power and
legitimacy required to be heard in every
stereo in the US people don't listen to
old town road because they enjoy the
song and definitely don't listen to it
because they're impressed with the
lyrical content instead they listen to
it because people love satire OTR is an
indirect criticism of rap country and
the materialistic culture that consumes
society today and then it goes out I got
a few emails like this claiming that Old
Town Road is is actually not a really
stupid awful tale terrible song it's
actually a brilliant satire of stupid
awful terrible songs I don't know if I
buy that I mean if it is then I'm a fan
of satire musical satire musical satire
that's so subtle that you might not even
pick up on it now I really respect that
if that's what this is but if this is
satire then I mean can't we now claim
that every bad pop song and every bad
pop country song is now satire I just
don't I I hope that's true but I don't
know if I I don't know if I buy it this
is from Vicki says Walsh I laugh at the
suggestion that the victim hole
you're starting from as a mere 75 victim
points tell me how could you be any
whiter you're wearing plaid for God's
sake well not right now but I guess I
was before how could you be any more
straight not only are you married but
you've sired several children and
impregnated your wife yet again how
could you be any more male the strength
and vigor of your beard cries out
against you I love that sentence the
strength and vigor of your beard cries
out against you that is a that is a
great sentence Vicki as such it is
blazingly obvious that you you are the
epitome of the dominant patriarchal male
oppressor I will give you the benefit of
the doubt and blame naivety for you to
put in yourself at only negative 75
points consider this what would it take
for you to reach negative 100 points or
negative a thousand or negative 10,000
nothing because you're already as low as
it's possible to go the depth of your
hole is incalculable
it's bottom is without limit you are in
the black hole of victim points and much
like an actual black hole there is
simply no excaliferb evidence of its
inherent truth so now that we have
established your true starting point any
more talk of credit points for your
temporary infirmity is just silly in
fact I could make an argument that your
injury and its subsequent treatment is
stealing valuable medical care from
those woke victims who truly need it I
am tempted to say that your temporary
disability might actually drive you even
further down the hole but we've already
demonstrated that this is impossible you
can't get any whiter straighter or more
male so on the scale of victimhood
you're digging in the Marianas Trench I
hope to help you sort this out and
you're welcome yeah Vicki I guess
I mean as I was reading that I began to
realize just how oppressive I am in fact
even in claiming that I'm a victim for
my temporary disability that makes me
even more oppressive and what I really
realized is that I guess I am
appropriating from disabled people by
walking around on crutches and having
this boot on and hobbling around on one
foot I guess now I'm actually guilty of
appropriation because as a straight
white cisgendered Christian male I can't
really be a victim which means I can't
really be disabled so that this is all
appropriation so I guess you're right
yeah I am I am deeply ashamed what right
do I have to have a torn Achilles you
know who gave me permission for that who
did I didn't ask anyone's permission
yeah I I am thank you for that thank you
for setting me straight this is from
Keith says dear Matt I must take
exception to your discussion of
Jefferson's attitudes
you said Jefferson didn't mean for the
Declaration of Independence to apply to
non-white people you might dig into some
history that's exactly on point
Jefferson's original draft of the
Declaration contained his intent to
outlaw slavery he was overruled in the
interest in including the southern
states in the new Union did you know
that and even the final draft blames
slavery is something inflicted on the
colonies by King George he hated owning
slaves but felt that in the absence of
abolishing slavery completely which he
could not pull off it would be cruel to
turn these illiterate people loose on
the public even if he could both sides
he thought would be badly harmed he
hated slavery and wrote against it all
his life he wrote in the first draft
King George has waged cruel war against
human nature itself violating its most
sacred rights and liberties in the
person of a distant people who never
offended him captivating and carrying
them into slavery in another hemisphere
or to incur miserable
death in their transportation tither
thither this is PI radical warfare the
upper book upper Boreum of infidel
powers is the warfare of the Christian
King of Great Britain determined to keep
open a market where men should be bought
and sold
he has prostituted his negative for
suppressing every legislative attempt to
prohibit or to restrain this commerce
Washington set up his estate to pay his
former slaves a stipend for as long as
they lived he too felt that merely
turning them loose will be cruel but he
had enough money to set up this fund for
his freed slaves ok Keith first of all
how dare you give me jefferson to read
publicly like that for the first i guess
i should have read that ahead of time i
think you understand i wasn't bringing
that up about jefferson in order to
argue that he was some kind of villain
who shouldn't be honored i think he
should be honored but at the same time
we should acknowledge what his
shortcomings were and and they were
significant shortcomings we should as i
argued all last week we should develop a
nuanced and mature perspective on our
historical heroes one that does not
ignore the evil they perpetrated but
also doesn't erase them from history
either so there's got to be a middle
ground and that's what I'm that's what
I'm advocating for as for slavery I
fully acknowledge and I believe that we
have to see slavery within its
historical context it was and it is and
it always will be objectively evil but
in terms of assessing personal moral
culpability which of course we can't do
with any exact precision that's up to
God but in a general sense
assessing personal moral culpability
when we do that we have to keep in mind
that slavery was an accepted institution
across the entire world for thousands of
years every country every race every
culture they all participated in it at
some point so someone who owned slaves
in the year 1800 or the year 1600 the
year 1300 is less personally morally
culpable for that
then you would be today if you went out
and bought a slave because you have much
more awareness of the evil of the
institution then someone had you know
back back in the old days with that said
I don't think a slave owner of 1800 can
be entirely absolved of guilt especially
if they did understand that it was evil
as Jefferson did as you mentioned and
you say that he kept his slaves because
he thought it would be cruel to release
them which okay but that that's a
rationalization that slave owners always
used that's the rationalization that
slave owners in the South and the Civil
War times used and they said hey you
can't you can't just go abolishing
slavery because I'm we're gonna unleash
all of these illiterate slaves you can't
care for themselves it's not fair to
them it's not fair to that it's not fair
to the white folk and say you know we
have to keep them enslaved unfortunately
and and hey while we keep them enslaved
I might as well have a few myself work
in that work in the plantation this it
seems to me is obviously a
rationalization it's an attempt to
justify something that you know is wrong
and it
to me it seems on par with the
rationalization that we have to you know
it would be cruel to abolish abortion
because if we did that we consign all of
these unwanted babies to living in
poverty it's the exact same kind of
thing but obviously the idea that it's
better to kill someone than to let them
be poor is absurd and just as it's
absurd to argue that it's better to keep
someone in Chains as chattel than to let
them be free and experience the pitfalls
of freedom yeah there there are
disadvantages and pains and miseries
that come with being poor but you don't
get to just kill someone and to decide
for someone ahead of time that they
don't want that and then to kill them
you don't get to do that and yes there
are there are struggles and misfortunes
that come with freedom but you don't get
to decide for someone that oh well you
know you you wouldn't want to be free
it's not worth it trust me your life is
much better now so I'm just gonna keep
you in Chains that obviously is not okay
so I think that Jefferson was
rationalizing an evil practice which he
recognized as evil and in the meantime
he was benefiting from it it's not as
though he said okay well you know
slavery is not abolished unfortunately
so instead I will just free my own
slaves and all let them live on our
property as equals you know he didn't do
that he still kept them as slaves
serving him so yes he was a deeply
flawed man who participated in a
horrendous evil that cannot be justified
even if his personal moral guilt can be
mitigated to some extent it cannot be
justified and his guilt cannot be erased
so that's just a fact yet he still was
in many ways a great man so both of
those things are true and and as
said last week that's that's the case
for a lot of great men of history a lot
of the great people of history men and
women many of them were they did great
things they accomplished things that
that no one else could accomplish
they changed the course of history for
the better but they also had a dark side
as everyone does but I think for for
great people just as their virtue and
their accomplishments are going to be
greater than the rest of us the evil
they commit is also many times going to
be greater than the rest of us and I
think just as a matter of studying
history honestly we need to look at both
of those and acknowledge them and factor
you know all of that in to our overall
assessment of those people all right oh
thanks for the emails we'll leave it
there thanks for watching
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show
our venerable media members over at The
Daily Beast tracked down that a furious
huckster who posted a video of a Nancy
Pelosi it was a joke
didn't matter today on the bench Bureau
Show